Hey nice to meet you
we kept put on the air that could ruin
us yeah we set things on the air cop the
air we are not allowed to set things on
the off the air we'd get arrested for
yeah yeah forget arrested well the thing
is we got energy from the spicy chicken
sandwiches that's not going to read
here's the thing for and we'll do the
read when we get to it but yeah for
probably three or four years now I've
been trying to get Brian to jump on this
Burger King train how many I got working
not every day but as a treat my aunt
nobody would take me to Burger King if I
did something good good grades good test
yeah caught a football touchdown
whatever yeah I'll get Burger King so
it's holds a special place it's funny
because they came in as a response as I
said no I don't need Burger King so I'm
not gonna not gonna sponsor me and then
you go I go jury demand you go all the
time and when I have a cheap meal I go
to Burger King correct and I was like
okay well that puts us I said let me
just talk to you B just sit on here's my
points yeah and I turned you and you're
a sellout well I did try everybody
sandwich they were nice and it's good
here's that here's the thing is I kept I
kept eating it that was nice it's very
very good we'll do the real in style
just saying it's nice man what's going
on buddy long time no see
nothing I'm just still coming down from
that from that empowering Oscars and
yeah they were buh-buh-buh boring yeah
not very eventful but you know I have
seen most of Bright's my job FC must
move so I think I saw all the candidates
for most categories except for maybe one
or two but yeah most of them I've seen
what was your favorite my absolute
favorite was shape of water real that
one yeah I was glad when I started
watching a little bit last night great
movie
I thought shape of water was good time
get out was just so original yep
um but you know and then three three
billboards is good I got to see that do
you ever seen anyone that barely yeah
three billboards was good but you know
overnight you know my favorite part of
the show with Tiffany Haddish
like the kudu was presenting she was
funny man she's just--she's she's
killing it man
kill with it yeah I've known Tiffany for
15 years no I'm watching her she started
to do at the Laugh Factory I think it's
17 years old no it's so wild this
issue's in a program she's taking Dom or
Aris comedy classes I know and Kevin
Hart
really according to Tiffany I think
Kevin Hart's the one who got her
you know who's who is her original
champion in this okay we like money she
was homeless
yeah man car like such amazing story all
that [ __ ] everybody's little help um
there's a good night I mean the Kobe
Bryant one Academy Award that's crazy
all right
did he win for what I didn't say it did
he write any animated short if you write
the thing or I think someone else did it
but it you know he's behind it history
behind it yeah it's his story you know
it's great to think about a guy you know
retires from basketball to win a frickin
Grammy what two years later it's pretty
nuts I've never I never watched the
Oscars because it's a party I'm not
invited to and I always sit there a
little bit sulky I I'm afraid I run away
from the Oscars that's a very
interesting person remember we're doing
that podcast a long time ago think four
years ago it but you think we'll ever be
at the Oscars you're absolutely not and
you were uh commentating on it you know
I'm part of it but it's not like did the
Oscars is one of those things it can be
one of those crazy things where you do
something you say see a lot of times
this stuff is an accident you do a movie
nobody's heard about look at the
hangover it was a little movie nobody
even heard about it was a what it was
like this this a bunch of unknowns
nobody guys three billboards was not
like the exact budget movie you know
shape of water was but you know get out
with seven years in the making a lot
that's seven years seven years yeah
Jordan had that movie for seven years
every time I hear about success stories
in Hollywood like that it's like it
takes forever to get it done it just
because people have to put money behind
it they have to believe it's a million
moving down then it goes to Indy and
then goes Sundance people like it's this
big buildup and then you know did you
see the picture of uh you know key and
Peele do you see
key celebrating when his boy 1 what for
no director now bring that picture up
chin yeah give it he's you know Jordan
and key & peele they've been together
forever bad MADtv dais and so when his
boys winning it shows him celebrating
it's just awesome cement its him in the
air like literally I've only met him
once but Mike taran killam and and my
friend Kobe is on his show and he's just
that guy he's just that he's just a
great dude they're brilliant a good dude
it's coming it's such a good dude I
click yeah wait let it load there it is
no great is 8 that's great that's what
you should do for your boy right there
correct it's exciting man how about
crystal I didn't even ask Chris to do it
Chris blast out my first episode of
below the belt and goes if you don't
watch my boy Brent Shaw's podcast you if
you don't watch my boyfriend jobs new
show on Showtime you ain't [ __ ] hey you
that's what friends are supposed to do
for each other's you know I like your
show by the way below the belt things I
think it's gonna be where people go to
get their fight talk oh right on almost
at a million views we're close it's
great hopefully by the next episode
we'll be there I think I think it's a
great great place to go for that stuff
well you know a lot of work to do you
start off and then you learn for what's
good you know that's all it's just
you're getting you know it's like you
put the song together I'm pretty sure
it's a great song yep it just takes time
no it's just try doing it man fun do it
I uh you're kind of busy yeah doing e
you dressing up you playing dress up on
E
mmm now let's talk about that outfit for
a second because my friend said watching
your boys at your boy Brendan Schaub on
on E
by the way what there's this dude named
Chris who I box with and he's a it's a
big kid he's actually gonna have his
first pro fight and he's just a big big
guy who played semi-pro hockey and he's
from Boston kind of a rough guy and he
kind of looks like you not as
good-looking as you
but but kinda looks like you he's in you
could if you didn't know you and you
hadn't really seen you but you'd seen a
glimpse of you you would go and in a
dark room and them like you fall there's
a drought yeah and there's a girl I know
who is with her husband and she thought
you were him and so she just kept
looking over and kind of smiling and I
was doing my jokes and he thought she
was into him and he's a big thug like
he's a big like I said to him I go
what's that what's a what's uh he said
this girl asked me what's the craziest
thing I got away with and he goes I said
I told her a bank robbery and always
good fella and she was like he was like
it was funny is that I was telling the
truth anyway and I was like oh [ __ ] like
he's yeah he's wrong yeah he's a Boston
rough and but anyway long story short he
thought she was trying to hit on he
looks like the alley cat version of me
Boston yeah like a rough-looking dude
and he came up and started hitting on
her husband you're not mad at that suit
came this well let's go back to the
static line up Stein tuxedo what is that
it's a custom client in Epstein they
make yeah yeah yellow is a burnt orange
mm-hmm know what it is it's supposed to
be like a gold like a gold yes polluted
river yellow I like the yellow you don't
mind I let her mind it see most people
go with the black tux I find that's so
boring no no I like it yeah I get man I
hear I thought them the makeup lay
[ __ ] up my hair but whatever there's a
right there your hair looks like it's
not sure what it's doing I know your
hair is right now your hair's fighting
the front is a slayer this way run
scored it's like messing the fries what
are you doing to me in the bike why are
you going over the side over here man
let's all work together here it's like
our country your hair's like our country
nobody's talking to each other it's a
melting pot yeah it's a melting pot and
everybody's fighting I only do my hair
myself and then I thought you know what
they're professionals let them do it and
that's what I got never doing that again
that's a problem because they are they
did calm did they call so many calyx my
hair's a nightmare yeah I don't know
what you're doing you got some thick
hair thanks bro Congrats
I had fun though that stuff is fun I've
a lot of pinyon I love it I I don't like
being a celebrity dick diver as far as
like Oh
there they are walking on their card
there they're doing this I have a ton of
opinions on who I think should win who
won the reception and you're not really
allowed to express those necessary oh no
they let me go kind of do my thing
don't let me do my thing now um it was
freezing though what did who did you see
at the Oscars who impressed you what was
are there any stories you're around all
these big celebrities
yeah me and Meryl Streep hooked up wait
a minute dude you can't just say that
and look around what why are you doing
that he said big stories bro listen up
what did you say
I maybe I maybe I misheard what you saw
a louder I might have misheard what you
said well I think Meryl Streep was real
Streep is she's the greatest of my money
the greatest actor actor actress actor
of all time of all time in my opinion
Brendan I think from the miming you're
making you look like somebody's lips
okay you're making sex you're seeing
death becomes her yeah okay okay bro are
you saying that you had sex with mouth
street whatever you want to make out no
no I know what I'm making out of it oh
there's my girl
your girl dude you had you hooked that
with Meryl Streep don't go don't go like
this like I don't know cuz I'm having a
lot of trouble believing you
where was it cuz I I know where you were
you got home at 1:00 so where did you do
this on stage that's that see I think
you're making all of it how is it the
Roosevelt Hotel which is across the
street where the first Oscars were yeah
that's where our was that's where our
studio was I know I'll have two parties
there so you weren't actually at the
Oscars they had you across the street
oh you separate no no typically we're on
we're at the awards it really always but
for this they were at the Roosevelt
across street which is so much nicer
you're watching on item screen
it's a nightmare if to go to the actual
complex security crate it's the most
security they've ever had for a wart
show really nuts Wow nuts man but this
this is what I was saying on
below-the-belt earlier and you give me
your thoughts on this B so everyone
knows the Ryan Seacrest you know kind of
accusations and they've done you know
third-party investigations they found
nothing to you know it's innocent until
proven guilty and then some people on
the on the on the red carpet the the the
PR people go we're protecting an
interview with Ryan Seacrest omits all
these allegations which i think is all
these allocation and she's a cowardly
move me to off see east under
investigation they think based off their
intense knowledge and their intense
details of the situation there's no
reason we should accuse this man so they
leave him on the red carpet right good
good I mean backing up Ryan Seacrest
which they should innocent till proven
guilty then these celebrities go I'm not
going to review with them because they
make me look bad and then Kobe Bryant
wins an Oscar I'm gonna Kobe Bryant fan
I love Kobe Bryant I love Ryan Seacrest
and then everyone of them who did an
interview with Ryan Seacrest gives him a
standing ovation is that not weird do my
thing is Hollywood pick a lane like how
like what would mean they'd have to have
some moral consistency and that don't
about that they don't yeah they don't
have moral consistency what Hollywood
does what Hollywood does and what actors
do is they they they want to be liked
yeah so they do what's popular to do
what's cool and I would remind people
that if you are going to a if you're
going to embrace a culture that says you
are guilty by accusation remember this
your [ __ ] next yep
the Dave Chappelle tells a very moving
story about Emmett Till Emmett Till was
the young black boy who was 14 years old
who a white woman said he whistled at me
okay and white men came into his home I
think four days later dragged him out of
his home in front of his family and they
found him in the bottom of a river
beaten so badly I think he was attached
to a wheel oh my lord him this was
nineteen look up Emmett tell me if it
was one of the main things that that led
to the two
the civil rights movement was such an
outrage his mother didn't let it go but
he was he was accused I think was the
40s he was accused of 1955 oh yeah yeah
1955 remember but Brown versus Board of
Education these were this was in the Jim
Crow South the Jim Crow South remember
what that was that was separate but
equal so in fact you were you were if
you were black you drank at a separate
water fountain you went to a separate
school and everything else Emmett Till
was accused on her deathbed this woman
said I lied okay but it's what it and
and the black community is dealt with
guilty by accusation forever forever and
been killed and lynched and so has so
many other people in the world
so you just say in that society there is
a reason we have due process in a modern
society and it when you embrace this
mass hysteria and you you take a guy
like Ryan Seacrest of all the thousands
of interviews accused once and a third
party investigation thorough
investigation oh me people work you know
I've worked with him yes a thorough
investigation says he's there's no
evidence here and the woman the woman
from my under standard used him asked
for two million dollars before any of
that threat okay but we live in a time
where if you even question the accuser
you're in deep [ __ ] if you want to
embrace that culture you're next well
how many people have we seen where
everyday accuse them they find nothing
the damage really done you don't see any
releases like actually Ryan Seacrest is
a good dude or name any other culprit
actually they are good people turns out
we did find anything that doesn't link
the headline no and and by the way the
woman who started this me to thing said
he should be snubbed and I'm like so
guilty back is an interview with her
guilty by accusation yes what are we
talking about here
don't you understand that's what leads
to terrible things there is a reason we
have due process look at the evidence we
have to be responsive to evidence yes
if somebody's accused by six people and
the stories are very consistent now
agree now I get it now what a harvey
weinstein might be like bro I got a I
got a whole lot this is crazy I agree
but my god
we're one [ __ ] accusation or
equipment you can't be ruin you
yeah I don't know that's weird that's my
thing it's more than weird it's very
dangerous it's dangerous and we need to
know that what else did you do this
weekend brother I lifted now um I
haven't talked to you since oh yeah one
hour couldn't gon showcase at the improv
couldn't gotten better I heard you
killed it things things went very well
sure let me I was texting Rogan he goes
I have no idea but wasn't around there i
text Evi takes everyone like dude does
anyone know Brian D it takes you three
get back to me I'm sorry buddy I was
busy I had lots of people ever who
wanted to talk to me afterwards either
way I couldn't gone better so things
good things good things all the things I
wanted to happen from that one hour
happen you ready man so let me get
moving yeah so I think I mean I'm talk
Simon talked about shooting my third
special let's put it that way love it
yeah I was there and Kevin Hartless okay
way over there and it was freaking I was
so blown away I'm you haven't seen Brian
you know ever saw oh really got blown
away never seen Brian never saw Brian Oh
sir you were in for a show dude I have
like my camera going to uh talking to
some guys outside just I thought it was
off we're talking about he was talking
about how great it was to really so I
captured it somewhere like on the side
we have to post that somewhere - it's so
freakin good thank you what do I do
thank you well coming from somebody
who's an artist themselves just things I
appreciate that
I always listen really closely to
musicians and artists because they seem
to DJ turn turn turn truth what I
expected man
really yeah soldier I tripped I was like
in my car going like what the [ __ ]
tripping out dude love live I've worked
so hard at that one hour so I appreciate
it and Kevin Nealon open up for you yeah
it was the best night you know that
there's something about that experience
where the home run that was the best I
that was the best I could do yeah you
know I mean like since all downhill from
there it's all downhill like there's
some times when you we wish they'd be
down there and you go that's the best I
can do and there's still work to be done
it's it's always I always say that [ __ ]
as far as that comedy it's a verb it's
always moving right but um it was good
man it was fun and Kevin Hart people
were there because Kevin Hart just relax
or it called my agents to do something
which is pretty flattering cool yeah so
I'm in talks with go figure out Netflix
or some I go
yeah well that that's all in the works
yeah good stuff is what closed out to
this so yeah tight-lipped I am about
everything come with that stuff until I
see it freaking I was in New York to
impress sir from 7:00 a.m. to 6:00 p.m.
for two days yeah but I went to a bar
stool and bar stool owns this lead
called rough and rowdy where they do now
50 matches the night it's 3 1 minute
rounds my boy Dave Pres Dave and my boy
KFC they want you guys co-main event
there next one oh man down Shane yep
that's awesome but why don't we will do
that should we do that or should we do
any one minute rounds oh so we do we'll
do three one-minute zzs great alright
that's good can we do that
April 13 yeah it'll be my 13th me and
Dave would be the promoters it's like
Showtime and UFC come together hilarious
I don't want to punch Brian anymore now
we're not gonna we're gonna have far
yeah let's go yeah have you seen I'm not
there to be all awesome yep for sure
bring up rough rough and rowdy
highlights for me and let me know how
you guys gonna feel after you see this
because if you just move around not
really gonna work like that let me show
you this top one maybe over the end and
we're not using a we're not using no I'm
not getting punched in the [ __ ] nose
and stuff I if this just like one of
those things is not gonna I'm not gonna
do that oh you mean a boxing match
yeah I'm just looking I don't get no one
I just I'm not gonna be teeing off on
really fighting with chin it's not gonna
ask you probably just clicked on any of
the rough from Rowdies and you see it
that's the main event
you know rap in David there's no one
here okay that's trying to fight Dave
yeah Dave who the owner of bar stools
president so they're shooting well that
I'm good
this is great text Who am I to play God
and so you can't do it you might think
up a text for Zach they have the worst
logo of all time so that's the actual
fight than I they have like ten you and
I are just gonna go to box burner Tim
Bob working you guys are wrong when you
guys are ready for this terrible
fighters I was watch some highlights we
were getting murked
like knock ya out cold just up it's like
a Fight League where they just get like
random people cuz yeah one minute round
it's like tough guy come yeah terrible
like just swinging for the fences
terrible fighters oh you never had any
boxing ever look at them hilarious yeah
that's embarrassing I won't be doing
that out to that yeah we'll get in there
and we'll get in there and we're gonna
do about that boxing bird how you do
that box and if you guys are scared
we'll do our own thing that'll be fun
yeah is it about that life yeah that's
not for you that's that's that's a real
mr. Singh yeah it's embarrassing
real real cockfight yeah also this guy's
Terrebonne though right dome though then
yeah Plato though rough we'll do it
ourselves
yeah boxes burn I've sewn pay-per-views
for that with headgear chin you're gonna
wear a bar I don't want to wear headgear
that's one thing you don't know why not
I can't see crap yeah if you're not used
to those suck I can't see anything okay
and I think it's mild okay it just hits
my yeah you have to have a mouthpiece
you got a mouthpiece alright I care
daddy see it you decide what he goes
down it is good no I'll have some fun um
have you been hit in the face you're
been hit
yeah yeah get ready take a wide face I
know that's why you have your chin on
him that's the one bad don't have though
like I have a small
I'm saying you not I don't have time not
saying that Jay Leno I'm saying if he
had punched you should be alright
should be a big noggin on you yeah it'd
be hilarious if Kalin flatlined you I
won't be hilarious
I will not speaking a flatlines you see
the fights this weekend this weekend oh
I tell you about that boxing match
goddamn let's talk about that for a
second first of all yeah yeah what a
warrior Gionta Wildrose and what a gutsy
dude to take on that [ __ ] I know
that guys are these great box are
amazing and just you know as good as it
gets fighting a southpaw what a
liability that's where I go I look at
down to water and I go you put it all on
the line you risk a shitload and you
were like I want to prove that I'm the
best in the world and fight anybody who
steps in risk is worth the reward cuz
this is the only way he's gonna get to
Joshua now Joshua's hands kind of forced
to fight oh man yes one before like no
he isn't beating away and be one then he
gets his Klitschko at the joshua moment
not like i you have to yeah so and by
the way um I felt like uh Deonte one
when when he was getting hit he was kind
of in trouble
it seems like he wasn't in trouble like
like so so he was like he was all loose
and getting hit you know he and I can't
70 round he got black he did but somehow
I felt when she has a chin like him what
it is no he was getting rocked
I mean helps keep so big he'll go back
but right but you know he got he almost
got looser and was just hanging on him
and just like kind of going with it cuz
what is that he was that what it is yeah
he was hurt but he had the wherewithal
to cut and when he walked back he just
went he was a he was lucid he was like
damn he's trying to act like yeah it's
he's a showman
for sure but he was wrong he got caught
well bad I thought I was it was looking
right they like each other a lot of they
got two children two daughters that have
special needs I don't know if they like
each other you know one doesn't speak
English that was that was [ __ ]
amazing such a good fight Oh such a good
fight so exciting how bad does everyone
see wilder Joshua now and then you know
Wilder the idea the Wilders wild and
doesn't have a discipline style for jab
his right that's straight right I mean
come on he's like a he said he goes I
open up when I when I got the guy in
trouble I'm a show
but when he's sitting there with that
strange old chaos but it is he's not
like a Mikey Garcia or you know where
he's in this he's the technically most
you know traditional box or what he does
he's 40 and Oh so it's stuffed are you
he also won a bronze medal in the
Olympics he knows that a box with his
sides he doesn't look like the
traditional boxer he was he's wild all
right yeah he is wild but yes he knows
what he's doing in that chaos it's 14 oh
yeah
39 knockouts yep we're crazy get that
jab that and that's straight right it's
also that jab stuff to pull off against
a southpaw and Ortiz and any time you
throw anything Ortiz would fire back
with just pure that's daddy that was the
most impressive thing to me Ortiz is how
schooled he was with that cross card
the meaning of the dropped Papa he never
and drop never been dropped shows the
power and death to Walter Wade 213 pack
which is actually light it's light for
him me but usually about 5 pounds
lighter when you house this so alarmed I
think is the advantage
how much did Ortiz weigh 240 Wow Jesus
would how would our teas have done
against Mike Tyson in his prime can you
answer that more gently I don't know
it's tough yeah Deonte would be a
tougher matchup for dad for Tiant days
yeah athleticism and just he's big dude
you know yep but the artis is a
nightmare no one's gonna wanna fight
that guy no it was all worried Wilder
was light I didn't have a problem I
think it's his advantage mm-hmm
stepped up did it knocked him out
knocked him down
crazy right in there in there in the
10th yeah now now it's Anthony josh was
so Wayne McCulloch who is you know knows
his boss knows his boxing he loves
Wilder he thinks wow there's gonna be
trouble
went out but you remember Anthony Joshua
has to get by Joseph Parker yeah
Joseph Parker from New Zealand is no
hell no Joseph Park is a nightmare
mm-hm they both have tough tough
Testament everyone wants to just chalk
it up Oh wild or empty Joshua but yet
Joseph Parker has this thing to say that
and he said he's never lost either never
lost no man all these guys are that
they're fighting get to these look
the superfight is a 90th at the
heavyweight division is exciting now
every weights are back baby
our back Ortiz is not done by any
stretch of the imagination now it's
Ortiz 57 he's been 757s yeah he's not
young no he's not going anywhere but
that was that was your mr. da he's 38
okay that's the Cuban thing that's a
Cuba that's a little girl canary gymnast
from China 38 yeah that's a Cuban 38
yeah great night of flights though and
rainy watch you'll see I did watch the
UFC what do you think well um let's uh
let's start from the bottom down girl
Kat lost my girl Kat lost I want to talk
about that lost Hector Lombard CB
Dollaway I'd watched it a lot I watched
it over and over again it was Hector
caught in the moment or was that a clear
just a clear violation
well definitely clear violation people
are gonna say well he's in the act of
the combo when he threw the shot
it's a tough argument I don't think he's
gonna be able to return it I have a C's
argument but now it's definitely late
sometimes there can be a weird
psychological thing like you don't have
the confidence in you
you almost throw I don't know it's
almost all self sabotage maybe but I
don't know that was really really quick
right this kid yes quick I can see his
argument but he still although although
she W look the bell goes off as CB kicks
so the bell does it watch watch it watch
it
yeah goes off after it so goes kick and
boom boom but okay put that Boom Boom's
in the motion in retaliation to the kid
I mean I can see the first one coming
down to the second right but the second
one Bop you know well that's what you
train let's say you do train that you do
Hector Lombard still bodied up see
that's a tough one man it boom-boom
yeah I gotta say man I think that's
forgivable why do the other videos seem
like good because cuz you're training
for that all the time so but you know it
was literally back it's close I don't
think Hector's a cheap guy or a bad dude
I think it's it's it's it's tough I
either way you got a DQ my finger on
that can see B dollar can't fight you
can't fight yeah we gonna are you you're
well Soto so I think it's a fair
disqualification I just it's one of
those things where you kind of feel bad
for Hector I feel bad for both guys yeah
that one seems a little longer just had
to here here's the thing you know you're
at the end of the round right you know
you've been weird like if you get the 30
seconds then you hear it you got kicks
stop I gotta get disqualified because if
you get this ball fight but in defense
of Hector too man
I think that would happen whether that
was a minute in the first round or you
know two minutes in the first round it
just so happened the bell rang you know
I'm saying so in other words that looked
like you know it's not like see be heard
and let his guard down he threw the kick
then kick an opponent what I would have
lost anyway another way yeah if there
was three more seconds in that fight
that happens it's not because CB let his
guard down right right which I it's a
shitty situation for both guys yeah it's
a shady situation anyway she Mackenzie
during the big kids see Mackenzie darn
right you need some work ah I was gonna
go over the yoga is the sleeper passion
obviously here though I know she's a
giant by utiful I know girl like God you
know she's a little brown she little
bushy little brown
little Brian I got a CO tongs just burns
as pretty as McKenzie marinas I think I
see odors even cuter how about that
that's fair that's very fair it takes
nothing away from Ashley Dern but you
know McKenzie during is world champion
jujitsu I believe right correct she's a
monster on the ground I still take
McKenzie over but I'm not I wouldn't I
wouldn't kick either out of the bed for
trying to do stuff do you feel that was
a good I was very close fight do you
think it was a I don't think it was I
don't think any we had cheated the guy
he's been of a ship fight yeah to be
honest yeah yeah I think Mackenzie
Turner has a job she has a lot of work
to do yeah I'm not mad she does a lot of
work to do but you know that she's a
specialist so I think she has to plate
with her tools and be a specialist not
try to be a striker and she's worked on
a wrestling because those traditional
jujitsu takedowns are tough for right
now yeah yeah
both he's also never wear those jeans
ever again that she wore at the press
conference please don't wear those ever
again yeah other than that I'm on board
I'm on board on board I'm on board
I like that fight moving on and then you
got you know the main card your girl cat
Zingano
you know long way off I'm a Viera fan
she's a monster I think I think it was a
combination thinking I think Vera's that
damn good but also cat Zingano had a
huge layoff so there's a little ring
rest there so usually off um I did feel
like she was throwing with her chin high
and her hands down along and I don't
know that I've seen that as much did you
feel that way did you feel like she was
quite a dear friend I just think she the
ring rust is a you know legit concern
it's a legit come to term but but your
evidence were down the whole time and
that seems to be like I kept waiting for
her to get caught with a counter yeah
what's that about a lot because you're
boxing a lot right in downtown and keep
your hands up so you're so
self-conscious of it but an MMA doesn't
really work that way right it just does
it doesn't look how Conor fights yep
look how that one does what Connor has
that right now Frankie Edgar fights
right no one's fighting like this B yeah
you're just so conscious of it cuz
you're boxing keep your hands up you're
a fool cause you're always waiting for
something to come back
Enza but the motion the distances varied
MMA is very yeah so get over the hand
stuff no one fights like this right
there's some that do but that's gonna be
tough right leave the hot elite elite
guys they're not really fight with an
anti hands down body takedown that's
right trouble you just sell round this
around it yeah get your hands up so when
I hear like with Jeff do all that I can
why is he have his guard up well he's
six seven six eight so his his body type
his style is different than what are
your traditional boxers yeah be he can
get away if he doesn't have to do this
to eating Brella he can do this yeah you
know the clips yes you know she she just
looked when she was throwing she looked
like she was she was leading with her
chin a little bit did she just looked
like she was opening herself up didn't
she
you know she's never been that kind of
world-class striker boxer but she has
been like to take she has beat a man in
núñez yeah but Wrestling College
Kimberly dim the boxes it is and also
like you said she's been out for a long
long time you know that she had some had
she had some she had yeah there was
there were there were things going on
where she had some health issues to and
she'll of yours is not someone you want
to come back for your debut that then
you've been gone fit she's a nightmare
yeah there are lousy Struve I mean sure
yeah can I ask you can I ask you a
question please it why isn't he in the
NBA number one who did you pick why is
he also not throwing one jab you ever
has you know I know he never I know dude
never use this breech ever but that's
crazy talk dude wait is this coach
Gordon I'm going hey jab always only jab
go to go pay to go to down Dante Wyler
and say can you show us how you use your
your your higher or you could even use
your jab like a Spartan front kick just
kick that entered your left hand just
kick from the other side of the cage you
don't can touch yeah but no and that let
him in I know he's never used his range
ever I don't understand that I literally
am confused that's that seems like
textbook one I want it be tough because
everyone's game buttons just to get
inside on you so he's used to fighting
inside to learn how H as I know me front
knee remember front also remembers
that jab he's seven foot tall basically
sixteen get under it it's you know you
can time and how long it takes with that
jab to leave here to they're about the
world-class athletes are like what throw
your jab Oh boom so you know he's not
gonna stick on the outside and pepper
you because yeah because he's probably
because he's private and a Mutombo
we hung out it takes forever to throw a
jab from here to there yeah her loss
he's a world-class boxer you know in MMA
so he'll just do that job please throw
that jab so a lot skin wants that that's
alright else it was wait for it throw
some couche Saturn bomb well he probably
has bad memories of throwing a jab so
now he's he's actually pretty damn
athletic 4/7 yes that's one saying pick
up a basketball son or or just or just
throw the jab anyway I just please rise
but New York do some and front do
something else didn't use your range Wow
I know no range Shana Lasky looks great
yeah who's relaxed he look fantastic yes
sir he's been fighting for 28 years now
he's been fighting for 37 he's he
started started fighting in the 60s and
he still did fighting in the 60s in
Belarus and just found his way to the
Orlovsky when he was younger man was
such a handsome son of a [ __ ]
he's no handsome though yeah his no
[ __ ] dad he's so macho oh my god you
see your area he goes to hug you miss no
no don't touch don't no no no I didn't
say that Salinas why you just didn't
want to be touched you don't he's before
fighters doing one you know you think no
no no touch before I fight yeah you
think no and that showed um Sean
O'Malley has superstar written all over
all does did he end up breaking is a
foot no no turns out no bones but yeah I
think it was maybe like the Michael
Chandler thing where you get kicked
there you check a kick and it shuts off
that nerve you know that shuts off your
foot that happened a cat yeah mmm oh
also also Andre when that happens maybe
don't wrestle him and just just take
advantage and circle around circle
around that foot we asked to pivot and
just pump pummel him with with punches
that was very interesting maybe Andre I
didn't want to win that way yeah I don't
know and then I obviously brighter tell
you a Frankie Edgar talk wow wow I don't
tangle with that little short elbow
you know he's Brian Ortega a very good
boxer right um you know he's not really
classified as like a great box he's just
he get what he is is a very good MMA
fighter yeah yeah he's knees kicks
elbows in the ops if you get a hold of
his neck it's game over he's just
throwing a fight max Holloway for the
title now yeah that's a fight internal
fight week in July on the DCCC Baker
he's just on below the belt no damage
from this 1:08 you dude you're unscathed
he is that nothing here's my foots a
little sore I think from jumping around
but you think I'm good Wow confidence
sky-high look man that's a real fight
him ins max max how a better striker
brother eight fight the Phenom will
fight best fight you can make in that
division
I think so too what am i for you think
that's a real tough one oh I gotta put
my money on it I'm done
Downton Ortega I don't know I added up I
ought if you look back at max max Aussie
be the favorite but as far as as far as
finishing five rounds good ground his
ground game who's - not even close T
City is that right Oh another on the
same key because he's on the same planet
what really even MMA no oh god no t city
is the best featherweight on the ground
by leaps and bounds
I just because she's a hair Dane Hunter
protege a night deep deep knowledge no
nightmare you if you if you expose your
neck for one second for the takedown
anything like that you're screwed that's
why if you what's that phrase soon as he
got Frankie's neck the whole crowd goes
oh they've know what stops and hit into
holder brassicas if he gets a [ __ ]
inch of your neck it's game over wow
that's why the fight so intriguing it's
max Holloway because also the you know
max usually the bigger fighter
Brian same size mmm Brian's long energy
- Brian doesn't get tired either they
both have great wind
great fight phenomenal fight I bet those
gentleman who were both young fight many
many of times yeah that's the fight
though and the Cypress cyborg has to be
in the conversation who said who
greatest fighter of all time
oh you want me to fight Yannick it's
Kyah he teaches the girl like scared
well who the [ __ ] about doping around
she not Warpaint she wears how about how
about doping around cheese I let's touch
gloves she's like a Jun Jie's dude no
you get hit by that you're like oh this
is terrible this is awful where I was
black
immediately immediately no I mean I
don't know I think Chris cyborg is in
the conversation as number one fighter
of all to climb on bomb Tony there's the
only person so Kat wanted that fight but
she heard losing she's so down the Kuna
but though the only way Chris cyborg
loses if they put more than one female
fighter in that cage I think there's not
a female on this planet Holly would be
the closest man that man a Nunez is
intriguing a man indeed his Toro handle
bombs I don't I don't get it I
I think she's undersized I you know she
man didn't is walking around when she's
not hot when even remotely close to me a
cyborg you've been around they're not on
the same planet they're two different
human beings well Chris cyborg is I'll
say I'll say this is only your defense
in your defense
Amanda Nunez is a more precise and
technical striker
however cyborg is pretty precise and
hits like a Mack truck and she's got
what's-her-name in her corner now her
striking is different
Cris cyborg is she's physically
different than any woman that steps in
there she did do we have to acknowledge
that too
whatever the case yeah I think it takes
away what she's doing I agree she's
under streaky side of testing she says
physically she's just she's just gifted
she's so gifted physically but you but
again let me just say this let me just
say this she she is her success is not
because not just because of her
physicality she has worked her ass off
to become in my opinion the best fighter
that a that best female fighter ever my
far yeah I agree so you can t be you
have to give you have to give credit to
her insane work ethic to her and the
amount of skill that she's mastered
everything credible she's good at
everything and seems to be getting
better and will fight anyone shaky let's
do it short
I'll make weight let's do it well I
actually think that I'd like to see her
fight some men I say that too I'd love
to see her fight to be please take it
easy now if you just jumped away
relax bro relax I'd like to see her
fight some of the lower guys down Basu I
like to you're fightin Barboza
Brandon I would love a cyborg Luke
Rockhold match Brandon you're being
sarcastic
hey all honesty it's for reals I'm not
being I'm not being silly here yeah
cyborg we're seeing Punk I'd love to see
that who wins
cyborg right side watch what I'm saying
without question all day but who's gonna
sink in that fight is there any other
guy but or or the 35 pounders just guys
in too big and strong for thirty five
pounder men yeah they all get dealt with
they all get dealt with she's not the
higher echelons but the other uh they're
gonna have their hands TJ Dillashaw it's
much smaller than where he's yes he's
gonna beat her up but he's got he's got
his hands full yeah you know it's not
walk in the park she's 175 walking
around I think if she hits hard men
hardest [ __ ] so you think that cyborg
the cyborg beats up CM Punk yeah I do
like bad I do too like the same way beat
up time I have another [ __ ] cosa kiyah
i 100% agree but how does cyborg do into
35-pound men's division
am I even allowed to ask that or am I am
i great are we doing crazy I don't know
we caught up in the moment you talk
about impact and weights am I am i
overstepping my boundaries I'll say this
Benavides you know I love you brother if
she caught Benavidez with a mean
uppercut she's knocking his head back
she's somebody to the 10th with so much
bigger dude so she fights like the
minions attack in group here's what I
here's what I say the men have to make
35 cyborg can come in at 60 yeah so Liam
[ __ ] up I believe that Sonya mess
dudes Joe and she knocks guys out yes
I'm telling you the only way she loses
unless you put one or more females in
there or she fight too dude I agree if
that
CM Punk she steam rolls through him I
agree but you have to have some sort of
battle of the sexes thing you have to
have CM Punk except that fight knowing
he's probably get his ass what Molly
watt which not squat do that
molly-whopped yeah cyborg is just a
different man I'm green Anna fights
though I was looking at her head and her
jawline in comparison shows I was like
she's a she's a nice person man - she's
a good person I believe that I'm a huge
admirer of her but she's built for war
is what I'm trying to say the woman is
built for war yeah she's she's when she
had that war paint on I was like you are
the baddest you you are just a warrior
throw and throw man built for war and
I'm gonna have my hands full with her
advice partner I'll tell you look at her
she looks awesome yeah I'm a huge fan of
hers in every way I'm a [ __ ] huge fan
of hers
mmm she's like she's been through a lot
man sure has Lily coming out on top Wow
well oh I got a dime piece for a dime
piece of the game Dave the gay Jesus
Christ
my piece of the day have you seen this
Penn State running back Berkeley sukwon
Berkeley have you looked him up frame-up
sukwon Sukhoi I think it's the Quan just
type in Berkeley Penn State combine
numbers he's ran the most impressive
combine numbers you've ever seen really
he's beaten Vernon Davis numbers what
he's the fastest guy ever over 230
pounds watched since 2006 he was gonna
be like the number two three pick now
the thing you'd be number one he's such
a freak oh and looks like a chocolate
goddess Riza good God not a chocolate
goddess no no goddess thing about pay
him up immediately yeah that's that's
that's a very symmetrical looking man
sukwon Barkley looks like he's very
similar so number one his 41 inch
vertical hold on his for 230 come on
here at a four-four 40-yard dash was
likely the second best ever by running
back over 230 oh my god ready his 41
inch vertical is likely the new record
for among all 203 pounders
that's so sweet on the flipside he bench
225 29 times well so check this out and
that I posted this guy is the black
sheep scroll down
Bryan Callen check this out Penn State's
running back sukwon Barkley at the 2008
combine stronger than Joe Thomas the
linemen Hall of Fame Republic quicker
than DeSean Jackson faster and Devin
Hester in jumps higher than Julio Jones
Devin here
salmon at ease to run Ponce down ah he's
only other drill the shuttle ranks
nicely too we already knew his workout
he's a workout beast go ahead and bring
him up working out great form
now how much weight is that bread that's
7,000 pounds 400 5 4 5 power clean
that's he's a complete frequent complete
freakazoid yeah complete freakazoid I
can't get enough come on
I watch it I record I need to watch it
late at night like a psycho yeah that's
a good-looking dude - yeah that's a
good-looking man he should be the first
pick I would like the Cleveland Brown
should take him for him and he's a
running back run back Penn State was a
stud at Penn State just a complete freak
man how about there's a gentleman great
for this you got two legs you got two
harms Brian sure there's a linebacker
from look it up June I think Central
Florida one arm one arm sir is that NFL
Combine he point hand one hand or what I
mean one arm he just its elbow only
elbow only and he put 225 up how many
times he supposed to get drafted the
first three picks I'm he sorry first
three rounds
yeah is one arm and you have to complain
show this guy you know what now I'm
pissed I'm pissed you talk a lot should
I have two arms I can't look at him does
he have a bird chest like you nope and
he has one arm
lettuce oh well the top linebackers in
the nation right he just wasn't born
with an arm he wasn't born with an arm
bro look at that bro and his arm is kind
of small and that part of his arm is a
little small
it's not interception he will be tough
but that's besides the point bad
[ __ ] right and you're me bro
that's a bad impression I mean I don't
do that
but look look at his stats for the for
the fricking combine man with one arm
that's crazy man I have no excuse not to
[ __ ] make it in the NFL now I know I
got to start sprinting I'm not doing
enough Sprint's I feel I think she came
she first law his name's shucks Queen
Griffin yeah DeSean Shaq weim any of
these names typically tread lightly no
you're fast
what do you mean I just mean like if
your name is Deshawn the wash Cecchini
ishani dushanyi
mallet donny LaDainian a lot of those
names are very awkward and hard to say
yeah what about it they've been made up
okay that's about it bro typically I'm
an air on the side I'm gonna say I'm
gonna go lately okay I'm gonna go all
right now does Watts ready does Jed
Goldstein Jed Goldstein Jarrod Berkowitz
is now on the starting line with Jed but
Jarrod Berkowitz Yin charming and Steve
fearwood Honda Sean back
Jackson DeSean Jackson shot DeSean upon
Jackson all Johnny LaDainian Jackson at
the starting line now I don't have to
see anybody who's running right now so
if I'm not trying to say if I said hey
be real quick just like we're doing this
office pool real quick
we're speaking who's gonna win the the
sprint outside with just a few guys from
the studio gonna race in the street okay
yeah okay yeah we got a Steve Fox here
Steve foxy Fox
we got Massachusetts or something or
certain house oh yes these from the East
Coast so is good up there
okay you got that right yeah nice tennis
and golf we have Chris Weinstein yeah
Chris Weinstein you know just all the
finance accounts yeah yeah yeah
laQuan dream on the kwon do
yeah let me finish I put my house on
that you don't wanna hear the other name
pass on that you know their names
no thank you one of the other names
can't see one look one okay you take the
crowd out there contine tempe mm-hmm qua
the quality but look at this kid and so
what's list of every defense play at NFL
Combine away and at least 225 pounds of
us sub for four and shake wine should
Queen Griffin any of the list
somebody gave somebody a hard time for
saying that Griffin is 227 pounds around
an official for three 840 a for three
somebody was talking about black men in
the NFL like or black black people of
West African descent tend to be faster
than say somebody from Asia or from a
white dude from Northern European or you
know mid Southern European ancestry and
the guy goes well if you could find me
one white cornerback in the NFL I'd
appreciate that I have a theory on that
that only get into but Delphia yeah
either way it's interesting yeah there's
a hole do it yeah and then that same the
sports genes on this guy runs in there
yeah sports gene that's hilarious
but there's there's in in black culture
that's that avenues more accessible
no no not a chance of no no God no it's
it's more pushed upon it's more this is
how you're gonna be success yeah let's
focus on this our plan white culture
it's no there's other things you can do
and there's resources for the white
culture and there's not as many resource
pack so if you want to be successful
rapper athlete and that's that's an
issue yeah so they're gonna graft it in
and hold tight when things get goin
rough cuz that might be their only
chance again now as far as a white key
go I can get my education I'm good of
course he's going to trial there are
there are fast white dudes of course
there's some breathless the only thing
is the only is that what I'm saying is
that so in the book the sports chain it
just looks at something interesting when
you say Africans are faster that's not
true that's a ridiculous thing to say
because Africa is the most genetically
diverse place on the planet in fact
somebody from East Africa is likely not
to be as fast as somebody from a very
where where you see the fastest people
in the world if you want to look at
Jamaica if you want to look at people
who come from a certain part of Africa
and from an ancestral thing you there is
it is from the Biafra coast it is from a
very very small specific section of
Africa but with my theory it's like it's
like when they go Chinese kids are
better at math hold the Chinese
environment pushes math more on those
kids so they they practice it more and
they're they're more they're used can I
give you even thing I give you even more
on that and you're right a lot of this
is cultural it's so it's not the Chinese
people are smarter it is it was a
malcolm mcdowell come Gladwell in his
book actually says that it's the it's
the Chinese people of China a Chinese
tribesmen who came from a rice farming
tradition why because rice farming you
work it's it's a very labor-intensive
crop so hard work is everything and you
and you have to be very mathematically
and you have to be you have to have a
serious work so when those families come
across a math problem it's easy they
don't quit they go it's just hard work
I'm gonna work through it what's the
same thing as like in what my brother
does in computer data and stuff like
that and computer programming all that
stuff they needed more jobs there wasn't
a ton of computer programmers in America
so they started this new program in
India when out India employs some of the
the most computer programmers in the
world
if you think they were born into that or
did they learn it do you do you think
they have a knack for
for a computer programming no they were
taught it they were taught these skills
and now they just took over so much
harder that's right they both so much
about this so much of learning so much
of learning is is contingent upon your
emotional state when you're learning
something so if somebody tells you
you're not good at math somebody tells
you don't have an ear for languages
somebody tells you don't have an ear for
music
it will impede your learning immediately
it'll shape these boundaries around that
side so you'll hit uh you'll hit a wall
and you'll be like and if you're if
you're if you're from the ghetto and you
happen to be black and the only Avenue
is open to our rap and sports where
you're gonna place your energy yeah and
so so much of it has to be change that
has to change where you have other
avenues and your pet your potential is
limitless in whatever you put your mind
to and if you follow the examples of
people like that Mozart's the greatest
example how many times you hear Mozart's
a great genius
it was here's the problem Mozart at the
age of three [ __ ] years old his
father was one of the great great music
teachers in Europe from the age of three
Mozart was raised every single day on
music and he sat at a piano every single
day for hours yes remember back then you
don't know if you're gonna live right so
he did so the first time he composed
something that was original was when he
was 17 so it was that was just a lot or
thank you have you just been around the
piano from the IPERS and by the way at
four after 14 years of practice every
single day better be queuing ever befall
[ __ ] write you a tune after four
thank you years thank you so with you so
there's so many of these things are
taken there's a book by Alan Garrett
called to create creative creative kurd
the curve that's not out yet and he does
this study on this seventeen you look at
it you actually look at it you can
liberate people dude you can learn it if
you if you practice it Floyd Mayweather
great boxer you know why can't read yeah
yeah but his father and his uncle were
great boxers who brought him through it
he's been boxing since he was three
years old correct you better be good
correct
so a lot of that takes the mystery out
of it so we jump some current events on
oh yes sir on this was shout out to like
it took Kwan Watson what's his name -
Kwan
Keane's Akeem Griffen Griffen Oh Lehrer
monster 14 the forty at linebacker I'll
take a chance on them over 230 those
running a for for some kids these days
are so fast me
hey and out there if you're listening
please if you ran a four-four in high
school or college or let's just say high
school you ran affordable that's its
official don't tell me yeah yeah I'm
first of all no you did I've never
happened now you did the chance of
anyone running a sub for for it that you
lying you're lying you're lying you're
lying where were your buddy Tulsa I know
I know I'm like and I what I say when we
walked up it Brian was telling about my
football passion is already I ran a four
five in the 40s you're Brian gonna know
you did it
no cuz I'm fast you went no you did it
he's dead dude I did n't ice cream they
didn't don't tell him that don't look
don't tell me and don't don't tell
Brendan man don't outrunning that let's
do some kind of engine chin what do you
been doing man your apartment looks
pretty sweet I saw you at that dead body
rolled up into a rug do you have to you
have to you have to make my role because
that picture everyone everyone's on me
about so I'll have to make fun of it
otherwise it's just apartment looks like
it's coming together yeah your voice
sounds good though thanks man I want to
get it you just been working on that
working here in studio here a lot here
so if you don't notice the wires
disappeared now outside the shin is a
[ __ ] soldier man again is a soldier
the more I know chin the more I like
chin right hey I feel the same about you
guys Gina's Gina's you should date what
else Jimmy yeah that was it man when did
the Showtime team set up all this blow
the belt stuff I haven't seen it
that was over hi I'm getting my days
mixed up I think is the weekend like I
need a studio designers for everything
man it's not you know this didn't fit in
the elevator
so we hate we brought it from the
stairwell Oh although I mean it below
the belt section yeah that the bricks
over there I like it that's cool I
really liked your show man
thanks brother I really did thanks I
thought your interviews were [ __ ]
great and those are my favorite parts I
mean I swear yeah I'm very biased
obviously cuz I'm gonna you know I'm
what you do I'm gonna like it but but
I'll be honest it like I was trying to
be really objective about watching it
cuz I had notes and I want to know I
want to help you out with that but um
like I just felt like I said to myself I
go this is this this to me is what I'll
go to because I love to I love the fight
game so when I want to hear about the
details and I want to hear about you
calling Frankie out on head trauma and
all that [ __ ] that we never see like
that stuff is fascinating to me and I
just found myself going this is exactly
where I'm going a little get my interest
my opinionated point of view and
opinionated but educated point of view
on the fight game you're so cool like
when I was in New York I filmed at the
Giants Stadium with Brandon Marshall me
and him get into it surpri I can't give
it away but surprising we had an
argument our NFL athletes but an MMA
athletes
surprising his argument well you would
say that NFL athletes are better he did
not agree Wow
it's very interested we got attention we
get into it well you could make the
argument that with with MMA and I've
said this before it requires more of the
human body and the human mind although I
have to be careful because play books
are this thick but but let me just put
it this way quarterback let's just take
a wide receiver right you got to run
your routes let me make my argument I
want you to give me I want you to give
me your so if I'm oh if I'm a wide
receiver I got to be able to do I got to
know a lot of plays but really I got to
run my routes and I got to run to where
the ball is gonna be I'm gonna have to
block I'm gonna have to shuck a very
fast cornerback maybe - there's a lot of
stuff I got to do but really I got to go
out and catch that football and run it
in the endzone there's a linear
progression with MMA I have to do a lot
of things one is if I'm striking I
better be able to box kick box and kick
all require different distances I better
understand clinch I better then
understand takedowns I better than
understand what I what happens to me
when I get taken down I better
understand what to do when I take
somebody down I better understand what
doing somebody has my back
blow the very rules there's so many
variables and oh by the way it's 15 to
25 minutes oh and by the way it's
fine it's scarier than football in a lot
of ways because somebody's trying to
knock you the [ __ ] out same in football
yeah but tell that to safety who rent
those now for in the 40s two and thirty
pounds absolutely awesome for that
receiver so let's just take it so most
people go okay you call play he runs he
runs an out route a five-yard out round
well let's talk about it so a play gets
called in the huddle then depending on
the defense that that receiver is gonna
have to know basically prior a thirty
chain command whether where the defense
lines up gives him what ends up with
their blitz at 30 change so so if the if
the quarterback calls a hot read if
there's there's a depending if it's zone
coverage main coverage to Tampa to
whatever the coverage is he has to find
what route is best suited for that and
know that the quarterbacks thinking the
same thing and end up in the right spot
now the right spots he's got the right
spot was called in the hole it depends
on the defense depends how they play it
so if he plays inside and he's pressing
he's man well we're not gonna run this
rat when I go inside we're gonna go you
know so it's a thinking man sport
without a doubt there's a million moving
parts yeah no matter what we call in the
huddle they're just controlled chaos
that we all know the controlled chaos so
if he goes here you should do this the
ball is gonna be there you need to get
there and there's there's probably seven
to thirty different routes he's gonna
run predicated off the safety in the
cornerback
there's a lot going into it then you
gotta catch that ball they gonna make
guys miss also the guy who's trying to
prevent from catching the ball has been
playing football since he was four years
old he's read never and he was first
team all-american and he was the first
round draft me once I heard he gets paid
million millions of dollars hitting you
in the own also there's thirty two of
them in the world and he's probably the
best one you know it's just the level
competition is so goddamn high yeah well
yeah he says there over time they just
they've kind of the roots of the idea to
be a better athlete I believe you have
to be a better athlete to get that that
slot one thirty two without a question
right I think you have to be a better
physically welcome to even play college
football if to be around yeah the most
you see I believe that what I'm saying
is the actual act of the sport the
actual act of the
when you have a specific job as a
football player as a wide receiver as
alignment versus somebody who has to
fight yeah different yeah there's an
argument for both yeah I don't know if
there's a right argument if if I break
it down as far as if you want to go
based off sheer numbers speed agility
quickness all that there's no comparison
if we're gonna go over the X Factor of
who has the tougher job getting punched
in the face so I'm going around sucking
weight losing two rounds how they come
back there's all these variables the
pressure of fighting computer from all
different animal yeah I don't think
there's a right answer yeah I was gonna
say as you're talking like the deeper
you get into anything the more intricate
it becomes so if you talk to anybody
who's really really good at what they do
they're thinking they're they're
thinking about everything right I mean
there's so much to consider to be when
you're really good at something we
always talk about this the [ __ ] devil
is in the details details are what make
the difference details I mean you know
you watch when I was watching the
downhill skiing when Lindsey bombers
were racing and bode miller was calling
on it the amount of variables you have
to take into account from wind to how
low you stay to how aggressive you are
in the truck
Wow how wide of a turn you take there's
so many [ __ ] hoping your boy who you're
obsessed with me turned the 50 year old
gale Oh Adam Ricky was there last night
no he was there last night he looked
like a dime piece too tall is he not
Paul he's not he's not that that damn it
one is perfect for you I want him to be
tall dashing that's my boyfriend you
didn't mention me five seven he's a
little he's little he said you don't
need a big beard oh I like Italy I like
a cutie pie twink with these Linux tiers
just slide your dick be honest well I
don't I think about I don't think about
that but not really be Gail well no no
listen if he's 50 game and he is my if
he's my jail cell if he's in my jail
cell
I'm not lasting more than three days
I'll be honest are you gonna bust I'm
buzzed three days because he's gonna be
lettin you in less than eight out he's
gotta say guys
we're locked in a prison cellular as
soon as I fell it's time to go to bed
ladies
click your loo diving well he's probably
crying because he he sat you dive on a
Dickens on bro you didn't last two
minutes without trying to suck this I'm
not trying to suck his dick I'm just he
might not you suck in that he might like
mine know what he might well here's the
thing here's how it goes don't be don't
cheapen the [ __ ] bro okay don't cheapen
it it's a Johnny amore locked in prison
hold on all right and I'm the warden all
right ladies keep it down in here lights
out
I think he starts to cry first of all
ain't nobody gonna touch you up in this
[ __ ] you're talking like you're tough
now listen up you're just as scared as I
am daddy knows both from our hands daddy
knows how to throw his hands oh yeah
daddy I'll take it to the ground
all right and I'm gonna teach you a
couple of things all right I'm gonna
teach you what happens well her parents
coming down I'm gonna come down there
I'm gonna get off my bunk I'm gonna get
down there in the second I'm gonna make
sure you make sure that nobody gets
nobody breaks in it and if somebody does
break in the cell I want to be here next
to you so I can fend them off what do I
have to do in exchange for your security
over for a sec all right wife it's not
the biggest bed it's good Oh God and
face the wall I think you're gonna suck
this Nathan Chen is only five five get
the [ __ ] yeah that's not true I don't
believe that he's six foot
Nathan Chen's five five thirty does look
sir ice skater I thought he was six foot
two no you did it sorry sorry I had to
ruin sorry everybody I had to ruin that
movie well I got distracted we were
having was about that sex with my
boyfriend but Nathan Chen's only five
five dude third ice skater oh I didn't
know that he'd not look really tall no I
don't really look at him before come on
long legs that's not him that can't be
maybe even skating forever no he's got
to be taller Nathan Jen's got to be very
tall now dude
not tall does look small that's
hilarious or tiny
I put CS skates like real big skates and
me wow I thought he was so much taller
he's fine I saw him I thought of you I
thought which counts here to suck his
dick well don't say that because I want
to go that would he go bro
I got a guy I give guy yo it's not all
your great that's not what I think about
bro I gig I was dying to [ __ ] you know I
think about just hi he's my cutie but I
got a guy who come down in this Teslin
dry man don't cheapen you're cheapening
everything I'm a fan of his
you fit your old game in there that's
nice - Stefan curry who's 6-4 he's so
nice short right shorter curry 6-4 6-4
yeah I don't think he's short cuz he's
around all these monsters all goddamn
day
thought I got 6-3 6-4 yeah um you some
kind of instant yeah probably put your
dick back in your pants please
dragon back in there there you go how
about Luke Ross yeah be in the face of
mom blue Cologne I saw his [ __ ]
commercial mm-hmm
way to go Luke you [ __ ] son of a
[ __ ] look at him look at him he's great
and some kid right there
mm-hmm bring them fights though lucky
one of them fights 33 years old good for
him and fashionable he gets back in
there soon areas yeah he's just all a
man areas here's Photoshop but he is
Ralph Lauren blue bro nice Ralph rough
one you know Ralph Lauren buddies you
and him and him here I was just with his
hairs better than mine no I miss all the
words yeah very similar your this
similar here yeah but they yes it's nice
here is it bad that I just looked at his
hair and now I want to wear my hair like
that that's not real Brian that's tomato
so I need a part no that's his real hair
I like his hair in he's thinning it's
thinning yeah but
it makes me look like it kid just a
rough-looking dear just have real arse
real Popeye looking [ __ ] like a Bluto
like a blue know like Bluto from Popeye
he's got a handsomer Bluto
I think Pluto might think of the Disney
characters blue blue nor Pluto little
thing no dog he's Bluto Brutus Brutus
Brutus no there's no blue Tyler makes
Brutus and blew it up but Bluto it man
you would say hey we ought to finally
share it with Bluto and Popeye yeah and
we never printed it though well that's
because we get sued no no no there is
their dog that's that's what I mean I
thought you're mixing Pluto yes I
thought brutto getting Pluto I knew I
wasn't crazy I'm just a bruh a Brian
real quick he does not look like him Oh
hold on there can be a more alls I
character than put in tom's of Finland
tom's of Finland tom's of Finland this
is this is awesome
this is this is this is it this is the
kind of guy what the Brendan likes this
is this guy's a famous gay artist from
the eighties seventies and eighties I
don't like this real look hey come on
now keep looking keep looking dude hey
bro I love Fame I don't like this yeah
there you go Brendan okay Rhodes going
on no you are a [ __ ] ah look at the nips
on this guy he's a cop not [ __ ]
around he's a famous gay artist tom's of
Finland look at those here guys do a
Shindong that's the bug got some [ __ ]
gym I told you I knew you'd want to see
more hold on hold on hold on okay we got
that guy upside down he's grabbing his
dog and the other guy that's a great
[ __ ] painting I've ever seen in my
life you know what there may be too much
for me
I would imagine being a dress like da
one guy's balls deep tell me I look like
[ __ ] Luke though right there tell me
that doesn't look like fun tell me that
my friend like the virus training ah
like a fresh man where's your mouth
watering come on guys
they are so those pictures are so
incredibly fantastically gay look at
that just really good work
it is good work dude oh whoa
guys an ice cream cone take it the [ __ ]
easy
now I just really dab it around like
it's a goddamn movie you know bro I
think most of our listeners are gonna
probably Google Tom of Finland Goulet so
you know what the hell were talking
about it is some graphic it's some
grilled on our chili give them well done
Ryan is rock hard everybody that's right
rock hard and you just they were showing
one word some guys getting banged in the
ass while suckin dick and brain goes
tell me I don't look like fun like look
let me in the future about God sorry
it's how good it's Monday so we always
hold on how did you even find this
artist by accident no for real because
Jimmy Burke is gay I don't know New York
you know you see it was he he was not
just in New York he was a very famous
scene in this are they even the 80s you
had to know Finland what oh yeah if you
were fly if you were banging guys in the
underground you had wise huh
all right did any of you see this coming
Mirko Cro Cop versus Roy Nelson Oh
Bellator 200 in London all right all
right
we've seen that happened before but crow
COTS been on a bit of a resurgence you
know Roy coming off lost in Mitrione
they're both along the tooth I'll watch
it yeah I'm not paying for it blood
watches now some 41 cro cop is white 43
uh 77 yeah fight your app support he and
long in the tooth up there you know
belters you inside check Liddell - yeah
yeah you talked a little bit about that
I'm below the belt
yeah yeah what can you do what else you
got - how about this one's this Oscar's
was yesterday you know who Frances
McDorman is yeah she had an Oscar got
stolen from her table oh hey this guy
actually take a selfie with it you got a
rest of it he stole it he stole her puck
and this one there what are you gonna do
yet well she's from three billboards she
was the big winner of the night
oh he's in the same art you like bread
like to say might you do bro
he thinks that be good by his dog Steve
what did Francis baby give it up so he
just tells her what do we offer our team
probably just crazy he's just a thief
are you talking away he looks like the
steerage having a word and hold you down
so I could do what hey no that's pretty
bad asset you took it from like how did
you get that you just took it off the
table
yeah that's what I just left it there
damn its impress oh yeah cause
everybody's talking you don't expect
anybody steal your goddamn know that's a
Bostitch move got into the Oscars who
knows this week anyway France he also we
don't know he's gate you don't say
what's up baby boys and you saw baby
boys baby girls that's a common
expression I've heard that before
I've been called baby boy I'm sure you
have no no not man I'm sure you have
your baby boy just swallows baby bird no
I don't do that whatever like one in gay
I don't think about putting it in my
mouth oh you told no no I don't think
about I'm not touching a dick you don't
say
look I don't also not I just don't think
I'm an ass man uh and I I'm a tractor
Adam because he's so pretty
Adam although the boyfriend okay he's
just adorable 51 he's gay man and I like
him very much as a person I like that
he's him so he doesn't give a [ __ ]
yeah and he's a good person you can tell
he's a good person creative - yeah
Francis is a huge one I say have you
seen three billboards no I gotta see a
good movie
yeah I'm shape of water three billboards
two ones you gotta say I well I've
always liked Frances McDorman her speech
was very kinetic it was like I think she
went up there really kind of serious and
she was I'll take it easy I know I loved
homeboy who won for a supporting actor
who got out there
one for three billboards and he goes
when I it was a great story is my
favorite speech of the night he was you
know so he won he kind of was the
favorite to win it who was he
Wow with the guy from Dover support and
Best Supporting Actor he goes up there
yours when I was in elementary school I
was a kid I was in class and the
principal Kim got me goes quick your
father's here and something's wrong Oh
Sam Rockwell yeah Bobby listen he's at
boxing all the time by the way so he
comes in too so he's in school he's in
like fourth or fifth grade maybe third
grade and his principal comes to his
classroom he's the middle of the day
school it was I'm so sorry your parents
know if is something wrong with your
grant but your father's picking up we
gotta get you out of here
he was oh my god he leaves his dad picks
him up and he goes dad what's gone with
grandpa yes or what's going on the
Granite's nothing we're going to the
movies parents loved movies they like
they encouraged them to like watch movie
Wow
that's news dad oh my god when I went to
the same acting school and in New York
City ladies and gentle really Sam
Rockwell what a great he's that's great
that Sam Rockwell one that's [ __ ]
great great speech - how that's a big
deal man yes you know and by the way a
guy like that could have easily become a
character actor and just like you
struggle for work bring bring up his
irons Edie I'm trying to see cuz he's
been in a ton of stuff but it it's he's
never like and one of those character
actors yeah you're just like oh I know
that guy can make it not a lot of money
not you know making a living made his
job it's great but one of the good guys
men um older ones the new ones it's dark
no no he's done that let me let me just
hold on it goes it just does a lot takes
take sport I think what keeps crawling
down let me see
so three billboards he's an effort
family keep inside well okay okay
no I'm trying to think what the point
dynomite what the sitter he's hilarious
ROI meant to he's good I rent - yeah but
you're right bu look at his resume and
he's also been in a ton of stuff
nobody's Northwest I call sheet but yeah
he's not like the the
died looking for jobs yeah not making a
lot of money the money doesn't go to Sam
Rockwell the money goes to the other
four actors they have the two actors
yeah he's never been had like that back
out besides this but he's you know he's
competing against his other co-star and
three billboards would hear some yeah
who they thought was gonna win he's
great too yeah Woody's had it what a
career that guy's hazing career true
detective unbelievable he never stops
working and she's about he was too silly
call me really fun Cheers
that's right played the dumb guy played
the dumb guy very well yes so did Joey
from friends played the dumb guy now
he's killing it
yeah he was in Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles yeah he's the bad guy in that
head thug 1990 what else you got Jen all
right
so recently Rick Ross if you guys know
who Rick Ross is the rapper huge hip-hop
rapper star there's rumors that he was
on life support something to do his
heart a chaplain got kind of strong you
know he does own that franchise right
yes that's where the Johno okay so after
the rumors swirled that he was on life
support 50 cent put out this picture if
you guys remember what this picture is
from and what line is run at rocky Rick
if he dies he dies if he dies he dies if
I break him damn it I must break you
if he dies damn why'd he put that it's
pretty it's pretty awesome right these
Saints have been on some weird kind of
trust irrelevant you got lied like he
got caught lied about Bitcoin you know
it's some weird times right now
Wow dark [ __ ] they've been feuding for a
while
come on man feud it over what who feud
sustained ages rappers he got shot eight
times long I don't think yeah a long
time ago let's move on yeah
you're also you made all your money off
vitamin water you're literally the
scrooge mcduck of hip hop yeah let's
stop back then toss oh that's not cool
that's not cool we don't is that it
don't yeah you got somebody down a
mountain you like if he dies he dies
Jesus Christ
well it's an assumption but it's obvious
that's pretty obvious I'm going to
yeah but what does she get junk off um
how about the rock accepting the award
jazzy
this was hilarious you see this no so he
was at the Oscars but his movie Baywatch
won the ba ba Z for worst movie Brazi
play this hockey not love over pumped
and very proud for my buddy super
dominated tonight pulling for you guys
to bring home the gold I'm also excited
because I was just informed that I - and
bringing home the gold tonight no not an
Oscar maybe one day but a Razzie Razzie
or the annual awards given out to
hollywood's worst movie and i have
officially won one for Baywatch but
here's the cool thing the movie was so
bad they actually had to create another
category I'm not kidding that category
the new category is a movie so rotten
you eventually fell in love with it
not kidding which means the [ __ ]
sandwich you have been eating is so bad
that you eventually started to like it
look maybe a watch with the best of
intentions it didn't work out like that
but I hum I humbly and graciously set my
Razzie and I thank your critics thank
you fans and and look at the end of the
day movie so rotten you eventually fell
in love with it
that's just the way love goes all right
go Baywatch
thank you for my Razzie give it to me
Oscar sup he's so great I'm so great
he's so great Baywatch was one of my
favorite Americans the rock you know for
sure one of my favorite Berry was yeah
well I like hilarious hilarious
talented is out all get the [ __ ] out and
it's good-looking as it gets it is cool
black and Samoan not a bad combo you
know what else jacket I thought that was
great on the hand roll I got one more
front barstool sorry what'd you say nice
it all natural all right this is crazy
so this is in China
this hot chick who's a social media star
she blur she said she posted that she
was gonna have sex with anyone for free
at this hotel they showed up they showed
up over 3,000 people showed up instead
of saying he'd scare pidove cheeto
finger dudes with Harlem
rage this hotel looking at us a
different team
and women if a man said I'll have sex
for free you'd have a couple of like
stragglers for the most part to this but
yeah so did did she [ __ ] you I know
nothing housing people around 3,000
people 3,000 dudes and can I can I see
what she actually look yeah let me see
if me and Brian would go there there's
Brian let's take a look at a profile
it's gotta be a better yeah that's like
you'll get a profile and then decide if
we'd show up to her hotel thank you
let's take a look come on guys let me
get her American Japanese Japanese no
she's Chinese Chinese [ __ ] Chinese some
I went to China some of the most
beautiful man I've ever seen really uh
yeah chin doesn't like the Chinese hard
to find work is it yeah although she is
with the bangs you're not go to the
hotel miss ye social media sex yeah see
if that worked
sorta the same pictures then we have
nothing else so far I'm coming out of
hotel damn she was arrested yeah damn
talk about a real real blue that's just
Chinese blogger named Missy E all right
dude showed up trying to bug ya guys
don't fall for that sounds like she was
dumped she didn't think three thousand
dudes were in a rush to her hotel room
is there anyone if they tweeted out hey
whoever in its close to you let's say
you're like what really would you rush
over there uh if it was real yes
you don't really I mean what if Wonder
Woman the girl from 101 was I K
whoever's the next ten minutes come here
I'll suck you off well I know her pretty
well enough I know y'all kind of no no I
know got your friend no but I've spent
it even around cuz Patti direct or about
saying no so you didn't no no no um
there's something about like a group
I've been invited to group orgies I have
a new bid on it yeah yeah you have to
yes I've been invited to that and I'm
always like I gotta be next to some dude
who shaves his chest who smells like
not hey Ted hey Don when you're done
yeah I'm not into it yeah the whole
thing is now if it's my boys if I talk
about it boys then we can only talk
about if it's we can we can shake it up
is that fair I guess yours at the Oscars
did you see her no I do not see her how
did she get it mmm no that's it
Pharaohs at the Oscars huh you guys come
see me this weekend were you busy Friday
Saturday Huntsville Alabama
Oh headed down there with math york
rocket science no that's right they're a
riot - they're gonna be a laugh riot
what's up guys what's up with all this
propulsion how about these Rockets huh
man oh man yeah you're gonna blast out
your address so they can suck you off
huh no don't say that
um but you you go and I'm gonna give you
a couple more dates okay
give you a couple you're not ready next
weekend I'm at levity live in Oxnard
Friday and Saturday that is March 16th
and 17th st. Patty's don't spend the day
I should say the night with your boy
Oxnard levity life and then I mosey on
down to Florida I'm in Tampa Bay on the
22nd that is sold out so we had the
second show I think and then Friday
Saturday I'm at Palm Beach Palm Beach
improv what our favorites I'm gonna be
at Palm Beach improv uh April that's
cool April 12 13 oh cool that's far from
now I'm there on the 23rd and 24th March
March I'm there a week a month later oh
man traveling 12 13 14 in West Palm
Beach and then Sunday I'm in Orlando
that is almost sold out and then after
that the following weekend I'm in San
Jose Improv Friday Saturday at East now
keep at kake.com
Brian besides Huntsville Alabama well
she you know I'm at The Improv West Palm
Beach
April 12 13 14 then April 19 20 21 I'm
at laughs Boston in Boston Massachusetts
laughs Boston Oh have you not done that
great club I do the Wilbur Boston Oh
and we're back
take small breaths I'm gonna have to
rough you up a little bit now you should
matthew [ __ ] you can kick me in the nuts
for that ya defect a.com for brian
myself as usual we love you guys this is
the final kid we're out